côté de l'otan ou encore du côté de kiev
des autorités ukrainiennes qu'on se
montre plutôt pour l'instant circonspect
et dans la tente tous déclarent ne pas
vouloir prendre les annonces russe d'une
désescalade comme argent comptant pour
l'instant bien sûr et attendre de voir
réellement le retrait des militaires car
différentes sources d'analystes
militaire justement hier sur les réseaux
sociaux par exemple disaient qu'ils
n'avaient pas encore vu du tout de réel
mouvement de troupes se retirent et la
frontière ukrainienne avec sa conscience
a concerné seulement des troupes qui
était en biélorussie donc pour l'instant
voilà il faudra encore patienter encore
mais tout de même on peut noter cette
ambiance cette atmosphère qui a un petit
peu changé certains signaux d'apaisement
qui semble venir le côté russe lundi
déjà pour rappel est bien une certaine
mise en scène entre vladimir poutine et
ses deux ministres sergueï choïgou et
sergueï lavrov qui ont tous les deux
expliqué que voilà et bien il y avait
certainement une issue possible aussi
bien la diplomatie et leur lavrov
contrairement à ses déclarations assez
offensive ces derniers jours ou semaines
s'est montré plus conciliant disant que
pour lui il fallait renforcer encore le
dialogue avec l'occident on peut aussi
rappeler que hier olaf scholz le nouveau
chancelier allemand était à moscou et sa
rencontre avec vladimir poutine s'est
visiblement passé dans une ambiance
également un peu plus amicales peut-être
souvent les conférences de presse qu'ils
ont tous les deux donné après alors tout
ceci intervient dans un timing bien sûr
particulier parce que il semblerait que
la russie voulu un peu aussi d'être
damer le pion est un petit peu c'est une
sorte de coup de poker comme ça alors
que les états unis de leur côté annoncé
une invasion imminente depuis plusieurs
jours et même pour début de semaine la
russie en bon tacticien parfois bien à
peut-être voulu voilà montré que ce
n'était pas du tout le cas et répondre
un peu à ce qu'ils décrivent comme un
alarmisme côté occidental